tu es un solitaire voir un ours pourquoi
pas te l'a déjà dit tu l'as lu qu'est ce
que tu ressens
bon ça me fait ça me fait sourire parce
que je pense pas du tout que j'ai que
j'ai un caractère de solitaire c'est
c'est une réputation ça qu'on m'a fait
que je traîne de 64 sous protêt score 64
j'ai gagné donc la transat en solitaire
bas pour pour la plupart du journaliste
il était de bon ton qu'un navigateur
solitaire soit un ours fuyant le monde
moi je faisais cette course en solitaire
pas du tout pour fuir le monde pas pour
être tout seul
simplement parce que sur le plan sportif
c'était une épreuve qui m'intéressait
pour saab on ya besoin de supporter la
solitude
il ya même pas besoin de la supporter
longtemps au fond puisque ça dure moins
d'un mois on restait seul moins d'un
mois pas grand chose en mettant que la
solitude ne fais pas en mer tout au
moins
peut-être que fait tous la terre
ça me poserait plus mais en mer non et
mais quand je suis à terre je suis pas
du tout d'un caractère solitaire
byette avec des amis c'est à dire que
j'aime mieux être tout seul il n'y a pas
de doute que d'être avec des gens qui me
sont complètement différents mais
mais je recherche plutôt la compagnie de
bons copains
[Musique]